i've enjoyed this man's work for many a
moon he's played the president of the
united states twice
um he played him uh played the president
united states in 13 days and also in
kingsman
the golden circle so the man who's
played the president twice amongst many
other characters and so many other
great movies um and television shows
he's also played
captain pike in the new star trek films
he is in now season four of the resident
which premieres tonight at 8 pm eastern
on foxy is bruce greenwood how are you
sir
i'm good how are you rich i'm doing fine
uh so
um to what to do i'm sorry i missed the
the big word thing
i love big words do you what so uh yeah
i mean
uh my guys here make fun of me bruce uh
because i
i i just sort of i dialed in on
precipice and i think
is that do i get half a word or is that
the big word they're talking about that
is a big
that is it's
it is it is it is my way of talking you
know what i mean like so
i i i know i'm a sports guy a pop
culture guy but i i
i've got a vocabulary i'd like to use it
you know what i mean
bruce yes yep thank you go for it i
appreciate that
uh well i've also played the president
count them
three times three times hey
i am uh i am uh i am i am sorry
uh mr president national treasure oh
that's my god
how did i forget that one
[Laughter]
to what do you owe this bruce three
times what do you owe this to well i
think
yeah probably the only people that are
qualified to be president now are
canadian
that's right okay there's that but uh
there's that
you got some qualities that i guess so
when when you get a script calling you
to play the president do you say again
like you've been there done that or what
do you how do you react to that yeah the
last one was the kingsman and i kind of
went
you know what this is the way to go out
playing a president with you know his
hair on fire and then
and admit with so uh so i so i think
that i've retired the president's the
thing for the most part
okay you know unless i get offered a job
no well i mean hold on a second i mean
has anybody ever created your face on a
on an actual
uh us treasury note has anybody ever
done that for you put that on the wall
like you're a president
of like an actual president i've been
i've been trying to pass those off for
years
[Laughter]
you've got well i don't want to get you
in trouble you got a printing press in
your basement is basically what you're
saying okay
very very good you know i've been around
long enough that i'm beginning to look
like washington
so there you go bruce greenwood here on
the rich eisen show um
so you are from canada does that does
that i i
i always feel stupid when i say this but
i'll say it anyway uh the risk of being
does that mandate you having played
hockey being a hockey
fan bruce anything no no i was a rugby
player a rugby player and a skier
so i i was uh i wanted to lose my teeth
playing rugby not hard
so you never you never laced him up not
on a slew not in a rink that never
happened
oh no i've laid i've laced them up and
you know panted around the ring but yeah
i'm one of those guys who can only skate
in one direction
oh i see what you're saying so you're in
a grinder were you a grinder what were
you
when you did play hockey at any point in
time oh no i never really played i just
you know i played a couple pickup games
and you know
the grinder would be exalting what i was
capable of okay i love it so skier is
that pretty much you said
that's that's your okay deeply deeply
into skiing i thought i could actually
make a living at it for
a while and um like literally
you thought you thought like yeah
literally like literally i thought i
could be a competitive skier but
um i got way too broken way too many
times so i had to find something else to
do okay
is there any sports team that you're a
fan of any particular team that you
you call your own bruce greenwood in any
way you know
you know i mean i've i've not
really to be perfectly frank i mean you
can line me up against a bunch of guys
who know
know nothing about sports and i'll be
the guy whose hand never goes up
okay i love that no kidding well you
know i just you know i
might as well cop to it rather than
pretend no no no
that was amazing you know what you
should have said because if you had said
you're you're a fan of the quebec
nordiks i'd have just moved on i'll be
honest with you
you know like you're a big you're one of
those die-hard nordique fans and i'd
have been i'd have drawn a complete
blank and i'd have moved on
you could just do it yeah i will i'll
look i'm gonna i'm gonna file that away
you should for future
that's your safe that's your safe words
whenever you're in a position like that
from now on
just blurt out quebec nordiks and then
that'll be again
when i'm a little bit in pain and afraid
i'll just go north fantastic
oh fantastic so so what is the film or
tv show bruce greenwood that you get
when uh you know pre-pandemic when uh
you're out and about in a restaurant
or wherever uh what would be what what's
the one that you
would get the recognizable factor thing
where's that from
yeah um yeah mostly uh probably star
trek and
double double jeopardy 13 days that kind
of thing but once the residents started
airing it was sort of
it was surprising that hey yeah you're
the evil dr bell oh you're the nice dr
bell what happened
right um yeah yeah so the resident has
been sort of surprisingly
resonant i like that look now that's a
big word alert there you go
bruce greenwood if you start using words
like resonant my my guys across the way
here are just going to have to mentally
check out that
you want to look that one up chris it
means it means deep clear
continuing to sound a ring there you go
very good
oh the human thesaurus we got that
we got that all set up um so uh is there
uh bruce greenman here uh on the rich
eisen show
so um when you mention of the other ones
uh star trek um i i how quickly did you
learn
that the people who are fans of this
uh this pop culture this iconic pop
culture film and televisions
they're very serious like that you need
to button yourself up in a way that you
know everything about everything about
the history of star trek and that you
have to play your character
appropriately did you did you learn that
one
instantly right yeah like
it was like somebody you know put an iv
in me and i got the message
really quick yeah that you
you better you better know it all and i
just had i had the cop just saying look
you know i i know what i know and i'm
not going to pretend to know more than i
know and uh
you know these are all parallel
universes and
iterations of you know different
iterations of the same thing and um
right you gotta roll with it i don't
know if quebec nordiks would work there
either bruce
i'll be honest with you you know
yeah i don't there were any klingons on
the quebec nordiques you know i don't
know if that would have
helped but um oh i hear they're pretty
tough so i imagine there probably are a
couple
okay fantastic so what what about the
resident do you think makes it so
resonant against season four is tonight
at 8 p.m eastern
on fox what about that yeah i think what
separates it from the pack is
the is that we really try to highlight
the tension between
care and commerce and um you know um
medicine and money and the and
that the two are in constant conflict
you know to give good care requires
require serious money and serious money
requires
not making the profit maybe they would
like and
uh and that's and so you and you know
in real life situations run up against
this all the time and all kinds of
in all kinds of disciplines but it's
especially critical
in when you're talking about medical
care and so we try and
you know yank back the curtain on that a
little bit and uh and this year of
course we were
we were trying to you know trying to
illustrate the the
the tidal wave of
the that landed on the front line
workers
so incredibly quickly and took such a
massive toll and continues to so
um you know we speak to that early in
the season and then
and then get back into the the nuts and
bolts of
trying to solve this this medical issue
or that medical issue along with the
the personal things the show's been on
the air long enough now that people are
invested in the characters personally so
you know nick and nick and conrad are
getting married
and you know all the all the stuff that
makes people's
it mourns people's hearts is alive and
well on the show but
again it does touch on covet and the uh
relentless grip that it is seeming to
have on hospitals right now
so the uh proverbial if you will ripped
straight from the headlines as part of
the season correct
oh yeah that's where that's how it'd be
it begins with that
so those moments that we all remember in
march when
all of a sudden you were just being you
know it was like you'd fallen off the
board you were being pounded into the
sound you know it was just
um a sort of unspeakable deluge of
of case after case after case and
mystery after mystery
and then um and that takes has serious
repercussions on the characters and the
characters families and
and uh you know exhaustion is a factor
and all that and things
and people make mistakes and people
react well people react poorly so it's
all
you know humanizing this impossibly
difficult time
and uh and then this was
they were writing this in the summer so
they had to say to themselves
what's it what's the world going to look
like in january
and they thought well you know if
maybe we'll we'll be able to pull our
way through it so what we're going to do
is we're going to spend the first
episode of the season
speaking to what happened at the
beginning of the epidemic the pandemic
and then and then take our masks off
so because you know nobody wants to come
home from work
do you have right i guess you could go
come over and
see people on television with math
conscious oh god give me a break right
right give me a minute let me just kick
back on the couch and watch these people
i care about
so um so we after the second the
second episode we take off the masks and
that again it's uh premieres tonight
season four of the resident on fox
at eastern time yeah you know you're
right so many people want escapism and
things of that nature that's why i show
like this one talking about sports and
pop culture
well while on occasion you know real
world does come crashing in
um that that a lot of people just yeah
the only the only escapism that we're
the only bit of escapism is the fact
we're not wearing masks the rest of it
is
is trying to reflect real world stuff
sure
absolutely bruce greenwood here on the
rich eisen show okay before i let you go
um
you got a good nicolas cage story come
on give me a good one you got one from
uh
from national treasure yeah what do you
got for me of course i mean
who works with nicholas cage without a
good nicholas cage story okay um but if
you haven't
i don't know if you have the time oh but
just a long a long time ago
when i was a a kid a guy friend of mine
came up and said
the lamborghini newsletter man there's a
guy apparently he has to leave
the states he's been chased by uncle sam
he's got a he's got a lamborghini 69
lambo orange
20 grand man 20 grand and i had
21 grand in the bank and i went and i
took it all out i put it in the paper
bag and i drove it down to this guy
who was this guy who was racing back to
greece because the
because uncle sam was chasing him i
bought the lambo it was a 12 cylinder
sideways right it's
like running on eight cylinders i put it
on a flat bed i take it to a shop
and uh and three months later my wife
says
you're not working we're broke sell the
car
so i so i sell the car i sell it for 24
grand
yeah and uh like you know three
ten years later i'm riding to work and
this guy i've noticed some lambo
newsletter on the
on the cover the of the card is taking
out the van is taking me to work like
yeah i
just have a lambo he goes you used to
what'd you have
i go well i have lamborghini near 69.
what color and i go yeah
it was orange but uh did you sell it i
would yeah i saw i made a little money
when did it sell what'd you sell for i
said well
like i sold it to 24 grand i made like a
few thousand dollars now like two three
grand man
and uh he goes look on the back page
and i look in the back page rich guess
what they were selling for
like four years later after enzo ferrari
died there's lots of speculation in
exotic foreign cars
i can't even 300 grand oh oh
300 grand man and i was broke
so so somehow this story comes up when
i'm working with nicholas dave
and um because he was because he likes
nice cars right yeah so somehow this
story comes up
and he goes that is so weird man
that is so weird i was just looking at a
lambo now they brought one onto a lot
let me check out yeah
yeah yeah i was looking at a lambo today
man
i don't know okay different world man
so he's just looking at a lambo and it's
just 300 grand because he's nicholas
cage and
oh no by then they were a billion
dollars oh my oh jeez
[Laughter]
no no no yeah sorry by then there were a
million bucks oh
well national treasure was good to him
huh i mean yeah
yeah so i guess it's not really a nick
cage story
no it's it's more of a yay it's more fun
if you could only have uh kept a hold of
your lambo
i guess that is the the moral of the
story is that uh if you're hold on to
your alarm
thanks for the call bruce greenwood i
really matter what your wife says no
that's well you know what i don't want
to get you in trouble uh
what are you doing i'm holding on to my
lambo that's right
that's right quebec that's the way it
goes
at least we left you with that one uh
hey bruce thank you for uh for the call
congrats on the resident being as
successful and um thanks for all the
good times watching your movies and tv
that was great thank you
thank you richard you got it that's
official bruce greenwood on
on instagram hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here